và bốc trái dưới biển ở Indonesia, hướng trong người mặt áo phao trên chúc tìm đường phát thần.
Phà hoạn sẽ ra khoảng giảng sáng 12, khi phà của Chuy Jasmín đang trên đường từ bà li tới lương bốc, khoảng 8,5 sâu,
lực lượng cứ hộ nhận tiền và điều hương hai chăm nhân viên, tầu cùng chức hàng tự hiện triệu.
Khi lửa lan dọc, hành khách khoảng lận tiền cách thất thần, một số người mặt áo phao nhạy xuống biển,
các tầu gần đó nhân trong tiếp cận đương người gặp nạn lên, kuy nhiên, sống cao tới bún mặt khiến công tắt cứ hộ gặp nhiều khó khăn.
Theo AP đến chiều 1,2 thần tàm, một chăm bẩy mấy 2 người được cứ và một hành khách thiệt mạc.
Gòn số này cao hương dành sẽ bà đầu khi chỉ in giận 1,1 hành khách và 1 bẩy thủy thuộc.
Phà còn trở gần 1 chăm phương tiện nhà trước chắc đang tiếp tục sắc mình số người trên tầu và điều trao nguyên nhân vụ trái.
Đây là vụ trái phản nghiêm trong thứ 2 tại Indonesia trong chưa đầy một tháng.
Vụ cám mơ, mù tiền áo sẽ tổ xa hai, ngoài thư đảo mà đù ra hồi tháng bẩy, khiến năm người chết mạc và cũng khi nhận số người thực tế trên tầu vượt dành sách đang kiế.